[Música]
i
ah
mi nombre es javier sirven yo me dedico
a decirle a las empresas de que cuando
van a morir esto me lo paso muy bien con
los bancos alguien de banca aquí alguien
de banca o estupendo
claro yo les cuento de cosas como la
inteligencia artificial no esto que que
parece que nos ha cambiado pero todo el
mundo no sé si tenemos un sistema de
inteligencia artificial porque la
inteligencia artificial ni idea sea muy
poca gente utiliza inteligencia
artificial pero es verdad que la
inteligencia artificial de internet de
las cosas todo esto ha cambiado nuestras
vidas y además es que todo está
conectado fijado
este es el hígado que bebió la leche
y dejo entrar al cerro que saltó sobre
la mujer que preparó el café preparar
café que despertó al hombre quien iba
tarde al trabajo
y condujo el automóvil que encontró el
lugar de estacionamiento encontrar
estacionamiento de estacionamiento
encontrado y alertó a la puerta que
abrió la sala de control
al abad que aseguró la información que
dirige las turbinas que accionan los
aspersores que riegan el césped y que
alimenta la vaga poli que produjo la
leche que llevó a la antigua que le
recordó al hombre comprar la leche que
fue servida por la niña
que amaba al gato que bebió la leche
fijaros que yo además esto lo declaró
llegas a una empresa y todos no estamos
con la transformación digital
bakú está la cas quien ha oído esto de
la transformación digital quien piensa
que le está haciendo
pues esto es lo normal tú vas a
cualquier empresa y dicen no mira hemos
puesto un crm hemos comprado y estamos
probando con inteligencia artificial
probablemente vamos a ofertar 10
resultados normalmente es este es decir
ni idea perdidísimo fijaros que más la
digitalización vino hace 2
hace nada hace nada 11 años 11 años
tenemos los famosos smartphone quien de
aquí ha tenido un nokia orgulloso llevar
ese ladrillo encima como volaba no tener
quien tiene uno que ahora está la mano
aquí en segovia lo soléis llevar porque
en invierno si no arranca el coche con
el frío sacas el nokia le pone las
pinzas arrancas al coche pero claro esto
cambió radicalmente un tío dice no vamos
a esto es el smartphone y cosas y tal
bueno muy caro no me lo voy a comprar
porque para qué voy a llevar aquí una
linterna para que voy a llevar aquí la
radio para que voy a llevar las llaves
del coche para que yo voy a llegar no sé
pedir comida desde un teléfono estamos
locos fijaros que la inteligencia
artificial es lo más exponencial que hay
lo más visto de la exponencial y de la
inteligencia artificial
fijaros que además va a pasar algo y es
que ya están en el mercado móviles con
chips de inteligencia artificial eso
quiere decir que el móvil piensa solo
como esto es capaz de ejecutar esto no
está conectado internet pero es capaz de
ver de reconocer objetos y esto lo vamos
a tener en nuestros bolsillos y esto va
a cambiar radicalmente ya una máquina es
capaz de reconocer una persona reconocer
a su dueño reconocer objetos fijaros si
es un cambio brutal también hablando de
cambios no siempre en europa nos
hinchamos siempre oye el imperio romano
nosotros aquí teníamos tal ojo mientras
nosotros andábamos tan en eeuu tampoco
creéis que éstos sabían para los indios
lo están éstos no tienen prácticamente
antigüedad sin embargo es verdad que se
han puesto las pilas y se han puesto las
pilas porque fijaron las compañías
grandes compañías mundiales eran
americanas y ahora las grandes compañías
siguen siendo americanas pero han
cambiado radicalmente no empresas de
tecnología que guay no tenemos ninguna
en europa qué curioso fijaros que además
estos se han cargado bueno han
revolucionado
la industria de la música han
revolucionado la industria del vídeo
quién tiene netflix aquí quien reconoce
que duerme poco
claro esto te a cambio la vida en las
redes sociales las redes sociales algo
que dices bueno esto no me ha afectado
no tal si van a esto oye
reconocer que más de uno habéis ligado e
incluso echar un polvo gracias a las
redes sociales pero es que más nos hemos
hecho expertos nos han ayudado a hacer
los expertos no porque ahora mismo mar y
mira qué cabrón ha recibido el whatsapp
lo tiene en verde y no te ha contestado
ahora profesionales del sexo del amor de
la música de todo porque además lo
tenemos en el bolsillo fijaros los de la
banca no la banca estamos con la
formación digital estamos haciendo
temas de startups hemos metido en blogs
en quien tiene de aquí una cuenta en
amazon
fijaros imagínate tú tías hipotecado
para toda tu vida un y un banco los tíos
súper majos te han regalado un juego de
sartenes piensa lo que te puede regalar
amazon si le metemos la nómina todos los
meses porque se va a convertir en un
banco 2019 veréis lo que mola cuando
llegas a tu empresa y tal y freno
ingreses médanos y te la perdíamos en él
no no aquí aquí porque porque esto
cambia radicalmente hablando de cambios
a éstos no se han enterado de qué va la
película no fue a rango ver fuera esto
es van a desaparecer igual que han
desaparecido un montón de puestos de
trabajo básicamente porque si tú
maltratas al cliente no lo cuidas no lo
tienes en el centro
te lo va a quitar una digital fijaros se
ha transformado la digitalización del
sector transporte las fuertes
se va a convertir en un servicio no
vamos a comprar coches los utilizaremos
los seleccionaremos y la gente dice ah
bueno estos de tecla es verdad la
digitalización fijaros una compañía que
prácticamente no existía está vendiendo
más coches en el último año en alemania
que mercedes y bmw juntos estos de risa
no nada esto es mirar a acabar la
pantallita oye que éstos han hecho un
hueco y han hecho un hueco además
gracias a la inteligencia artificial fue
el primer coche más o menos que conducía
solo y fijaros si van a cambiar las
cosas os suenan estas compañías un sí a
ver que levanten la mano que les suenan
las compañías
de que te suena la última guay
bueno pues guay es una compañía de
software y cesc de software claro es el
sistema operativo de google en el
sistema operativo de google que hace
estos haciendo sistemas operativos
alguien de aquí trabaja en google
todos trabajamos en google fijaros nos
han puesto una cosa maravillosa gratis
igual que el wasabi demás y nosotros
cada vez que buscamos un patinete
buscamos patinete y vemos fotos y
seleccionamos un patinete estamos
enseñando a la inteligencia artificial
de google a conducir coches con sal
cambiar la contraseña hace poco no
habéis tenido que demostrar que sois
humanos qué imágenes te ponen para
reconocer
señales matrículas casas escaparates
coches llevamos varios años enseñando a
que un coche conduzca solo y gratis
bueno trabajamos todos para ello fijaros
qué puede pasar si google se pone a
regalar el sistema operativo uruguay mod
igual que hizo con android pues es una
revolución que va a llegar muy rápido
porque además es un negocio dice bueno y
esto es porque se meten por muy fácil
porque el negocio de ellos es cobrar por
la publicidad y si tú no conduces y
puedes estar así o puedes estar
durmiendo o puedes estar viendo netflix
la publicidad que vas a ver en el coche
es brutal y es un negocio enorme es
decir el futuro que vosotros os pensáis
que puede ser de automóvil no el futuro
es de las famosas industrias digitales
fijaros que además esto ya se ha
publicado google va a poner taxis por la
calle claro aún no he visto ningún algún
taxista aquí no he visto ningún taxista
a su android de google y hacer
vaya me vas a quitar el curro
fijaros que además los gafas estos los
google los amazon los facebook y los
apple lo dominan todo y luego lo dominan
todo porque lo han hecho bien estos hay
que reconocerlos todos además tienen
unos edificios alguien he estado aquí en
silicon valley
o en san francisco el que maravilla no
está todo allí súper guay las cosas
frescas todo súper mb especial de
linkedin de que aquella zona realmente
no es una zona aquello no es un lugar
sino realmente es una mentalidad y
pretendemos en europa hacer lo mismo que
en eeuu
bueno allí han tardado 40 años aquí
queremos hacerlo en un añito fijaros que
esto es brutal vamos a llegar en muy muy
poco tiempo y hemos hablado de la vida
de la forma de vivir la vida en el 2045
una sola inteligencia artificial es
decir sólo un cacharrito
pensara o será más inteligente que toda
la raza humana pensando a la vez y tú
dices
claro 2045 oye que esto falta muy poco
27 años nada más quien de aquí quiere
vivir 27 años hay gente que quiere morir
bueno pues esto lo vamos a ver y el
próximo negocio que no nos hemos
enterado tiene que ver quizás con la
cocina o quizás con la salud o quizás
con lo que vamos a comer porque porque
hemos digitalizado algo hemos
digitalizado el adn hace 18 años se
digitalizó el genoma humano es decir te
dan en un disco duro en un pendrive lo
que tú eres para que te puedan colar
para que sobrevivas el coste ha bajado
radicalmente fijaros tanto ha bajado que
ahora puedes pagar un estudio genético
por menos de 200 euros en amazon y te
van a decir probablemente de que vas a
morir o de que vas a enfermar y esto va
a cambiar radicalmente pensar que hemos
digitalizado la salud igual que hemos
digitalizado la música hemos
digitalizado un montón de cosas así que
fijaros la que viene y dices
nos hemos metido nosotros en estos
seguros pues no aquí están los de
siempre los de google los de facebook
los de amazon porque porque es un
negocio y porque es digital y de eso
entienden incluso hay una compañía que
se llama cálico que está dentro de
google que piensa darte la vida eterna
esto es por si dices no no yo ya no
quiero nada no quiero ni correo
electrónico ni tal oye te interesa ser
inmortal porque a lo mejor te interesa a
quien de aquí quiere ser inmortal
quien de aquí quiere ser eternamente
joven estoy además no fijaros que amas
eternamente joven como victorino y como
rosa rosita no te podrás ir de bares
podrás estar pero con 140 años estarás
allí dirán que hará que hace esté aquí
está de todo no verá para frenar que van
a sacar al team del ayuno xaquín cerca
esto va a cambiar porque además la
digitalización es salud
no vamos a morir enfermos nos vamos a
morir vamos a morir sanos por viejo por
desgaste fijaros ya que hace unos años
conocí tuve la oportunidad de dar una
conferencia era la tercera vez que
hablaba en público este es
bosnia fundador de apple fundador de
twitter ya los dos que habían ahí no nos
conocía nadie ser el mayor experto en
genética y biogénesis sintética alegó
oye de que que voy a hablar de avatar y
alice avatar es una tío
sí voy a hablar de esto yo la genética y
te dice mira no habrá nadie en silla de
ruedas vamos a poder clonar
extraterrestres yo pero esto en mucho
tiempo dice nada en 50 años en 30 años
claro haremos lo que nos dé la gana pero
tardaremos 20 años más en clonar
extraterrestre si vos crees en los
extraterrestres y dicen hombre no los
podemos fabricar y es estupendo el caso
es que me dejaba súper tranquilo pero da
la casualidad y esto sí que no lo sabía
me lo hace muy poco me lo dijeron
hace dos años se están haciendo ratones
llamados avatar en españa y es para
curar enfermedades como el cáncer y esto
son estudios que están haciendo
españoles los mejores investigadores de
genética están en españa porque son
funcionarios esto ya lo digo porque lo
bueno la mayoría se han ido y se han ido
como george george urss está en china y
george church trabajaba desde hace cinco
años en una cosa que seguro que os suena
a todos os suena esto a alguien le suena
quien dice sí que le pregunto
bueno lo explico rápidamente esto es el
corta pega de la genética básicamente es
una herramienta de edición genética
yo puedo quitar la información que me dé
la gana de cualquier archivo genético en
eeuu están haciendo vacas sin cuernos no
dicen nada para que quiere una vaca que
da leche con cuernos o sandra klepac y
payne pom pom pom vaca sin cuernos
pueden hacer lo que quieran los chinos
se dice que han arreglado 58 casos de
cáncer el año pasado
chris pérez el editor de vídeo pero o el
editor de la excelsa pero en este caso
de la genética y qué es lo que estamos
haciendo pues nosotros en europa siempre
hay a tope no pero los americanos ya
llevan más de mil millones invertidos y
por cierto son las mismas empresas
y nos dominan que tienen toda la
información nuestra los microsoft los
los yahoo
todos estos todos estos ya están en eso
y nosotros en que estamos bailando y
viéndolas venir de hecho cuando hay un
gran avance tecnológico ya nos ha pasado
a los de google los de facebook los eeuu
se pone a hacer negocio venga va tira
p'alante los chinos se ponen a copiarlo
y lo mejoran y qué hacemos en europa los
regulamos esto se nos va de maravilla
fijaros que además la inteligencia
artificial está muy muy unida con la
genética de hecho hay algoritmos de
inteligencia artificial que se sacan de
la genética de cómo se ha transformado
una célula o un organismo durante
cientos o miles de años eso significa
que con la inteligencia artificial vamos
a cambiar todo y vamos a cambiar cosas
como ésta todas estas enfermedades van a
ser tratables y curables os lo prometo
en los próximos diez años no morirás de
sida igual que ahora no mueres hace 15
años te costaba la vida pero
probablemente tengas cáncer dentro de 10
años pero será un tratamiento y además
en un tratamiento probable
de salud que pagues un fin por ellos
fijaros georges se está haciendo piezas
de repuesto en china un hígado tal la
primera puesta en escena de la edición
genética en humanos ya es inminente en
europa no en eeuu y los chinos fijaros
que ya no te sonará esto de vivir 150
años 120 años porque más nos vamos a
vivir con salud y sabéis lo que ha
pasado recientemente que esto es lo
grave y lo importante y es que la comida
también se ha editado o mejor dicho se
ha secuenciado fijaros el genoma del
trigo tiene cinco veces más información
que el del cuerpo humano cinco veces más
y este verano hemos conseguido tener la
genética completa del trigo imaginaros a
hacer harinas para celíacos imaginaros
hacer alimentos sin calorías y nosotros
en vez de competir contra bueno mercados
extranjeros que es lo que hacemos
nosotros luchamos script fighter esto se
nos va de maravilla nosotros normalmente
no pensamos en ir juntos en colaborar y
tal no nosotros normalmente pues oye los
holandeses con los italianos
los griegos con los portugueses de
normal bueno los franceses con los
españoles los paños con los franceses
digo yo que nosotros con los españoles
tampoco los españoles somos muy de tal
pero usted
los franceses la verdad es que no se han
dado pero bien bueno pues fijaros aquí
una cosa importante conocéis monsanto
quien piensa que es malo monsanto esto
fíjate vamos a hacer un juego quien
piensa aquí que el círculo del 2 es más
pequeño que el 1 quien piensa que el
círculo del 2 es más grande
el círculo 1 es más grande alguien lo
piensa bueno pues no son exactamente
iguales lo que pasa es que si entro en
la dinámica bueno pues va a saab fijaros
monsanto que eran los malos los han
comprado unos europeos y efectivamente y
monsanto que además tenía edición
genética pues pues resulta que vamos a
tener un problema un problema porque
efectivamente monsanto ya es europea y
la compañía más grande del planeta que
efectivamente era muy santo nos hemos
casado con ella y como nos hemos casado
con ella pues ahora es el enemigo
fijaros la cantidad de noticias que
están negativas en los últimos tiempos
sobre monsanto una compañía que sí bueno
puedo hacerlo hecho bien puedo haberlo
hecho mal desde luego ahora va a ser el
culpable porque esa es europea y en vez
de apoyarla bueno y lo grave es esto si
quieres sacar una ley y quieres esconder
algo a lo largo del año que mes
utilizarías para que nadie se entera se
agosto vale perfecto pues en agosto del
los agricultores franceses y ecologistas
han conseguido que la edición genética
crisis porque es el futuro de todo
y prohíba en europa bueno le han puesto
unas trabas brutales y vamos a tener
muchos problemas de hecho cuando hablo
con científicos hablo con gente tal dice
tenemos un problema grande ojo tenemos
los mejores expertos en genética los
mejores expertos en genética en el mundo
y vamos a volver a desaprovechar esta
ventaja que teníamos fijaros que además
la dieta mediterránea es muy probable
que desaparezca o que simplemente
tengamos que pagar derechos por ello así
que pensar que en vez de luchar y
prohibir cosas lo que tenemos que hacer
es abrirnos porque bueno estos gafas la
verdad es que ya se los han puesto
difícil a todos y no vamos a tener el
chef en la nube vamos a tener pues a los
médicos vamos a tener a los agricultores
vamos a tener poli matas que es lo que
tenemos que ser tenemos que tener visión
no tenemos que estar encerrados el
futuro es de los polis matos de los
polis matos creedme y pensar que la
innovación no es la que distingue
precisamente los móviles a los líderes
sino la perspectiva y mi consejo es que
dejaros de inteligencia artificial y
sobre todo tener más humildad humana y
para terminar mi consejo kung fu panda'
y de verdad que es un regalo porque por
eso se llama presente gracias
[Música]
ah